in this video I'm going to walk through
the three-step process of going from
side hustle to main hustle so first
things first I'm going to define a side
hustle as a main hustle that has not
gained enough size to support you
financially and this is an important
delineation because if you're just
trying to make side money then to me
that's a distraction from what your real
main hustle is which is probably your
career if you have a career or you have
a job then I'm a big advocate of the
reason you should have this job is
because you're trying to learn and earn
and it should be probably geared more
towards learning than earning especially
in the first decade once you have some
of those learnings if you want to just
make your own money then you take the
skills you have and you have to make
your side hustle really your main hustle
and my objective here is the number one
first secure your family financially
which means live underneath of your
means with just the income from your job
your side hustle will also hopefully
start making some income once I have a
certain amount of savings which for me
would be like six months of living is
what I would feel comfort with before
starting my next thing and it's exactly
what I had when I started my gym I see
50 grand for my consulting job over two
years living far under my means only
making 50 000 a year in order to have a
safety nut to make the next step I'd say
fifty thousand dollars and for me I
lived on less than that just do the math
on your own the next step is that I need
my side hustle to at least match my
income from my current role now is there
an exception to that if for some reason
you're only able to work on your side
main hustle four hours a week and you're
doing half of your income as you're
doing in your 40. then I would look at
that rate should be like well in four
hours I'm making half of what I'm making
40. if I had the other 36 hours back to
add to my four would I be able to match
that if you can use logic and say yes
then I would say I'd feel comfortable
making the jump but if you want to be
safe which many people were trying to
make this jump which is just so you know
the single hardest jump in all of
Entrepreneurship is going from the
safest thing which is a job to being 100
eating what you kill some people are
really easy for it it was not easy for
me so I want to Stack as many things in
my favor to make that at the lowest risk
possible that's when I started an online
business and I got 20 of my friends to
pay me 200 bucks a month each when I
started my side hustle I actually
started a charity project where I got
all my friends to pay me 200 bucks a
month to do their Fitness and Nutrition
programming from home and I donated all
the money they gave me it was about four
thousand dollars a month at one point
when I decided to transition to my main
hustle which is just going to be Fitness
I didn't even start my gym yet but it
was enough that I could live I just said
hey would you guys mind paying me
instead of the charity all of them said
it was fine and I transformed four
thousand dollars a month to charity to
four thousand dollars a month of income
and that's how I was able to quit my
fifty thousand dollar your job for a
fifty thousand dollar a year online
business and that's what actually gave
me my living expenses when I started at
my gym while I was reinvesting stuff
into hiring more people buying more
equipment things like that that I
couldn't afford in the beginning the
phase three there was that I had seen
that they had sustained the level of
donations for a six-month period and
then when I asked them to go to four
payment that was my big risk and they
said yes and so then I felt confident
that I had sustained this level of
income from my side hustle for an
extended period of time and that
ultimate really gave me the confidence
to jump into the new thing and to be
fair I actually moved locations during
that period of time and dramatically cut
my overhead so like I was saving really
aggressively but when I wasn't sure the
money was going to come in my rent was
first zero because it was just the gym
but before that just when I got to
California I just rented a bedroom from
a guy that I met at the gym for 400
bucks a month and he wanted me to live
there because he wanted to get fit he
gave me that discount and that's I mean
use what you got right and so I would
meal prep every Sunday with him and so
he got a little bit of value from that
which I got to have a discounted payment
and sometimes he'd chip in on groceries
for my food like I've maintained my
relationship with that guy for a decade
now some of those early people who help
you out I think it's always worth
remembering them and so for my first
phase of saving up I saved fifty
thousand dollars making fifty thousand
dollars a year over two years which
means I was living on like a third of
what I could possibly live on at that
time because I wanted to save up this
nut to go all in on the thing I wanted
to do now I didn't know how sustainable
that was and this is probably something
you might not have thought of is that I
want to sustain that level of income for
six months all right this is like orders
of risk you have the savings you've
matched your current income you're
living below just one income which means
you're banking three quarters what
you're getting paid probably and then
three is that you've shown that it's
reliable because if you just the first
month you match your income you quit and
then the next month you drop back down
to zero or one quarter because you're
doing gig work or whatever that's gonna
be really stressful it's going to affect
the work you do it's gonna affect how
you sell and honestly it's gonna affect
every other aspect of your life and so I
would want to see consistency what side
hustle do you pick I want the side
hustle to be something that I have a
high likelihood of success with which is
something that I have some sort of
experience with one of the easiest
things to do is take whatever you're
doing in your current role is start
doing that as a contractor 1099 Etc do
those companies have the most Enterprise
Value no but you can make some money and
learn some basic skills in business that
you would have no other opportunity to
learn you'll learn how to hire people
you learn how to fire people learn how
to have hard conversations learn how to
drive initiatives you learn how to
Market you learn how to sell to get new
business you learn how to contracted
invoice you learn how to process
payments learn how to set up an LLC
there's lots of things that you have to
learn just going zero to one now if you
have a longer time rise and do that
you'll figure those out as you go but I
would say that you don't need to be
perfect on the first pick you just need
to be directionally correct and the
first direction is I'm going to be an
entrepreneur so if you make the first
jump you've already taken the biggest
jump in the right direction of what you
ultimately want to do it is very very
very rare that long-term entrepreneurs
first business is their last business
look at every single person that you
look aspire to and look up to in the
business world with the exception of
Zuck and basis the thing that they
started is not the thing that was their
biggest thing Andy frisella had some
direct response brick and mortar store
thing and he was like painting Lanes in
parking lots I think Ed my lap was like
selling Insurance stuff I was doing
personal training online what you start
with is not what you're going to end
with but it will give you the stepping
stones that are necessary to get to the
higher leverage opportunity in my
opinion one of the bigger mistakes
people make is they try and go to the
big leagues before they're ready and
then they fall flat be willing to do the
basics because realistically I'm
probably not besos I probably not
Zuckerberg and you might not be either
and that's okay and so you don't
necessarily need to model their path you
can model one that decreases the risk
because besos had a Wall Street Finance
job at a hedge fund he didn't need to
worry about money and if he quit he
could go right back to the hedge fund
and make probably a million dollars a
year Zuck was a Harvard grad Dropout
whatever he could get a job if it failed
at any top tech company immediately and
if you don't have those prospects you
need to be in my opinion a little bit
more respectful of the risk that you're
taking on and if you're a kid and you
can live at home or you can live with
four buddies do that if you can get your
living expenses to be so little that you
can cover it with part-time work like if
you can bounce at a club on the weekends
for two days and you get the other five
days back I think that's a net win but
the biggest part of this is like how
much overhead do I have to cover in my
life that I'm burning hours on the thing
I don't want to do long term to do the
thing I do want to do long term
massively cut your overhead so that you
get as much of your time back to invest
in the thing that you want to do most